[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
well there was a kid who hated me he's
dead now anthony kruger
he died yeah he accused me of robbing
this house and they bought from his
house
i never robbed him [ __ ] him [ __ ] him i
don't give a [ __ ]
bro he's dead [ __ ] him let him roast in
hell for selling blood
when i was using drugs i used to give
you pills all the time
yeah do you remember that oh yeah please
yeah i'd eat him i know you i know you
wouldn't
yeah yeah yeah yeah he wouldn't even ask
me he would just look at me
and i would just pull it out oh wow and
he would just eat them and i just eat
them yeah why yes i trust
yeah if the fda approves them [ __ ]
we're good you know what i'm saying
don't be giving me that ching ching [ __ ]
make my dick hard for two days yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah got to get off my text i
don't want to get another text again
are you guys on a group group right now
there's there's a group text battle
going on
between texas
who's the other guy on your guys's
tactics i don't wanna i don't wanna
get textured in the morning people going
back and forth like idiots
yes no yes no just call me and get it
over what are we gonna do
i can't see these idiots in 20 years
with cancer on
to you their fingers all the time see
i'm saying all you have to do is call
that's it
just call him hoping those people are
gonna cancel their fingers
from now a generation of a bunch of half
[ __ ] kids with mogul fingers and
stuff
they can't can't wipe their muffler they
can't masturbate they can't do nothing
because they came from a generation of
fasteners
that's what happened they didn't drink
tomato juice and they text people what's
up
like everyone says that as you're
getting into an entrepreneurial thing
and you're like first of all stop saying
entrepreneur whatever the word is stop
starting up
stop saying that [ __ ] [ __ ]
american word that just makes you stand
out like a [ __ ] momo i'm an
entrepreneur
go [ __ ] your mother uh a teacher a
professor in yale one of those [ __ ]
schools
that taught that twin babies how to swim
at 11 months old and how to look
underwater and
and it was just brilliant so when my
wife had the baby i go let's sign her up
at the y
so after six months we signed her up at
the y
and i would go to hawaii and i would go
in there with my fat [ __ ] titties and
[ __ ] y with my water with my daughter
and my wife
and i noticed that all these white kids
had mexican mothers and i'm like wow
that's [ __ ] up all these white ladies
adopted these mexicans
how [ __ ] nice of them yeah and i
realized that they were nannies
and the parents half of them were half
of them weren't there
and if they were there there they were
texting
so wait a second you're a parent and
you're the
the hardest thing for your child is to
establish trust
and i'm a [ __ ] criminal yeah i was
raised
by a cuban [ __ ] nutcase so
uh if i saw this what the [ __ ] is your
kid gonna turn on there's no trust yeah
you ain't sitting there sit texting with
your tattoos on your leg
and your [ __ ] kids getting learned
how to [ __ ] swim
by some lady that's illegal if isis
comes in your kid drowns
because she's got to run out of [ __ ]
pool your kids are gonna you know what
i'm saying
immigration watch them scatter you can
manipulate them easily oh i was there
with joe rogan with fear factor i had
women say to me look me in the face and
go i'll do anything to meet joe
yeah yeah what's the story
and then you always give them like a
code you want to play the flute
okay when you want to chase black people
out of your neighborhood you don't call
the ku klux klan
you put a bed bath and beyond in a
[ __ ] name but
nothing scares black people more than
bed bath and beyond
they read that word beyond and that
[ __ ] with black people that word beyond
they don't like that [ __ ]
beyonce i'm on but beyond i don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about the
denny's house was a very complex house
you had mike denny and a sister who was
beautiful and they were twins
then you had the older danny and then
you had a medium denny who thought he
was jimmy page
he quit high school when he was like 9.
he just played the guitar by the park
and he would try to be like that dude
that was like very coolish
but the claim to fame of denny is he had
a chick that would suck your dick on
demand
so if you'd see denny he go what are you
doing right now nothing
suck his dick
so she she never sucked my dick i could
be strictly
and you're not telling the truth i know
you i saw him a couple times and he was
such a creepy dude
and she was and she was good looking but
then
one night he took it to a party and she
sucks 22 dicks
come on i heard she burped and came out
at the end and said who's next
so then i heard like a month later she
blew 18 more guys
come on so he started calling a marathon
woman
and she would sit in class and people go
marathon marathon
i'll never forget her taking a picture
she was a year older than me and looking
at the yearbook
and seeing her like you know like
marathon and then like seeing like her
name like mary whatever her name was
and most likely to succeed and i'm like
she sucked 40 dicks
in two nights without even burping you
know what i'm saying like
so that was the claim to fame to jimmy
that was a lot of dicks
bro this chick sucked she broke the
record
she broke the record she had a record
break what am i gonna do with a
oh girlfriend i got 55 year old nuts
they look like they're 55. for a young
girl to suck them i wouldn't get no
satisfaction on i'm just
[ __ ] somebody's world up yeah i'm
just [ __ ]
somebody's world right yeah it's all
different now again
yeah yeah they just changed the alarm is
black yeah yeah yeah the map
okay you scared me i thought my phone
was going downhill and that was a
[ __ ] warning right there i don't know
sometimes the [ __ ] phone goes black
and you don't get a [ __ ] advance
warning now you're gonna go to sprint
and stand online like a [ __ ] jerk off
and they don't know
there's always a by the way with you i
love sprint but every time i go down
there's always
an extra 20 minutes and there's a minute
where you want to show there's a minute
when you're in sprint that you want to
shoot yourself in the [ __ ] head you
don't have a cold
i was 16 and a half and i was hanging
out with danny and he goes bro
we gotta figure out a way for you to be
able to drive
i go then i got my learning permit but i
can't
because [ __ ] that [ __ ] about a week
later his father called mr denny call me
at the bend he's like you got a minute
come over
i went over there mr denny's outside
there's a driving school guy with a
little hot car
with like drivers yeah yeah it's like
then he's driving school it's like his
cousin's truck
i walked up he's like give him a license
[Music]
give him my life write your name down
kid
i wrote jose diaz i lied on my
i lied on my date of birth i wrote it
for it to be 1962 instead of 63.
the guy gave me a receipt and i had a
lice if you watch any show from the 70s
when you walk into somebody's office
they got bottles yeah with no label on
them
and what did they do they didn't ask you
yeah was that the party out tonight no
they just poured you a drink and handed
it to you
you didn't say oh is is it scotch i'm
gluten free
he said oh no i can't drink that i'm on
medication
you just banged that out you just banged
that out you didn't ask what it was
if it's vodka is it locale you know how
you find out you start drinking it right
if you can make a reality show about
anything
what would it be and who would be on it
courtney kardashian that's the oldest
one with the two kids
uh yeah yeah that's the one i like and
it'll be a reality show about me beating
the [ __ ] out of a husband
and then at the end he sucks my dick
even if i'm not gay he's not a principal
because i'm 51 what are you going to
call me gay for 18 years what do i got
left
i don't give a [ __ ] that's kind of
[ __ ] i am well needs an idea and
i run with it jack
i don't teach you that [ __ ] at [ __ ]
improv olympics
you know you learn that [ __ ] in court
what level are you probation you know
what i'm saying
i
nothing would happen i thought i was
damaged goods
you were trying to have a kid we weren't
trying but it wasn't happening either
yeah it wasn't happening so we just
moved on with our lives we got cats
we adopted like six strays yeah and
that's what you do and they were my life
and uh and then one day she's not gonna
donate she's like you knocked me up
and i'm like you gotta get out
[Music]
[Music]
oh
just the wrong way